Hey friends. So, you've got down those
windmills and now you want to put them
to work. But how exactly do we go about
doing that? Well, I've got a combo that
I think you're going to
love. Drex here from Drex Factor PO
sharing with you the love of PO spinning
and flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And today I'm going to be
teaching my first combo tutorial in
many, many, many months. Uh, and
hopefully helping you apply those
windmills in the process. But before we
dive in, I just want to give a quick
shout out to the friends of the channel.
Big thanks to Dark Monk, Fire Mecca,
Flowfests, Flow Toys, Parer, Light Toys,
and Ultraoy for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible. You can
learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links down in the
description of this video. And special
thanks to the non-b business friend of
the channel, Pekka Becklanin. Thank you
so very much for supporting my channel,
my work, and my mission. So, I got a
request recently for a combo tutorial. I
haven't done one of these in a really,
really, really long time, but I do have
a combo that I've given to a couple
different students as well as posted on
my Instagram that I think those of you
who've just learned your uh windmills
are probably going to love. So, let's
check it out. So, this combo consists of
five eight counts. And the good news is
that you really only need three po
tricks in order to get it down. You need
your windmills, of course. Uh, you also
should know how to do your archer
weaves, both forwards and reverse. You
can get by with just knowing a standard
three beat weave in forwards and
reverse, but the archer weave is going
to look prettier. And also, you probably
going to want to know how to do some
stalls. Now, I'm going to include one
other optional trick in this, which is
tuck turns. Um, tuck turns are going to
help you out with a specific part of
this, but there are no points in this
combo that are specifically tuck turns.
You'll you'll you'll see what I mean
here in a minute. So, kind of the theory
behind this combo is to take a PO trick
that I think a lot of people consider
kind of basic, which is windmills, and
structure the combo in such a way that
it feels like when we arrive at the
windmills that uh it is a payoff that
there's a catharsis to getting there.
So, it's about structuring and also kind
of pacing the combo in such a way to
make this move feel important. All
right. So, just to start off here, I'm
going to walk you through the combo bit
by bit, and then I'm going to go ahead
and give you the counts for it. So, it
all starts with your hands and poi
reaching over to your stage left. And
you're going to start on the one of the
music. And that's going to mean that you
do the top part of your windmill going
over your shoulders first with your left
hand and then your right hand going over
to your right and stalling over here on
your right hand side. Crucially, this
part going over does feel a little bit
like a tuck turn, but in split time. All
right, so our next move is that we're
going to take this back to stage left.
Basically doing the exact same thing,
just these little tuck turns, but in
split time. Same direction going over
our shoulders. It's going to start with
your right hand and then your left hand
hand is going to follow. So we go right,
left, we stall, stall, back over to
stage left. Next up, we're going to
change things up just a little bit.
We're going to do those same kind of
tuck turnsish feeling things that as we
go around our shoulders to our stage
right, but we're going to wind up in a
place where we stall the right hand po,
but not the left hand. It's going to
continue spinning clockwise in front of
us in wall plane. So, just to review
that first section, we go over to our
stage right, left, right going around
our shoulders. We go back to our stage
left, right, left going around our
shoulders. As we go back over, we have
left, right, and the right hand stalls.
The left hand keeps spinning here in
wall plane. All right. So, next up, the
right hand is not going to be doing much
for a little while. It's mainly going to
be stuff that the left hand is going to
do. And the first thing it's going to do
is we're going to do a little pa boom.
And that's going to cause the left hand
to go around in a very big circle. All
right. So, the right hand is going to be
just hanging out over here on the right
for quite some time. We're going to do a
lot of stuff with the left hand, though.
Starting with we're going to perform a
little pa and get it to go around in a
big extension. It's going to come back
and spin at our hips for a little while
longer. Then we're going to do another
pa. Boom. And we're going to take it
over and around our shoulder in a little
shoulder reel here. And we're going to
wait for our next big move, which is
going to be That's right. to arrive at
our windmills. So the version of the
windmill that we're playing around with
here at first is going to be Poian Man.
That is this big version right here
where we are taking our hands and po
around in big extensions on the front
side and bringing them up close to our
ears on the back side. Now we're going
to be doing just
one two of these big windmills and then
we're going to do one two three four
smaller windmills up top. Once we've
done the smaller windmills up top we're
going to go ahead and start on our
archer weaves. I'm going to take left
over right, left under right, and then
over to the reverse side. Right under
left, right over left, right stalls,
left stalls. And that's the end of the
entire combo. So, to review the entire
thing, I'm going to go from my stage
left to my stage right going over my
shoulders and stalling. Then back to
stage left. Over my shoulders and
stalling. I go back over my shoulders,
stall the right, keep the left spinning.
Playa, do an extension. Hang out for a
moment. Playa. Do a little beat over my
left shoulder. And I do Puvian man once.
I do portion man twice. High and tight.
One, two, three, four. And then weave on
the right. Weave on the left. Stall the
right. Stall the left. And that's it.
All right. So now let's assign counts to
all of this stuff. So we're going to eat
up the entire first eight count. Just
going across to stage right. It's going
to be 1 2 3 4 and then five six we focus
towards the audience. 7 8 our focus
returns to our right side. The second
hand count is going to take us back over
to our left and also get us to the point
where we have that left hand spinning
and the right hand stalling. It's going
to look like this. I do 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8.
Basically, what we're looking at in each
case is that going over our shoulders
takes up a two count and we're either
making the moment kind of sizzle for a
second before we move on or boom, we're
speeding things up just a little bit in
order to get to our next step here. All
right, so the 38 count is going to be
with that right hand hanging out just
literally hanging beneath your right
hand. We're going to start on the one
that's going to be in our our extension.
And so we go around 1 2 3 4 and then 5 6
is the beat behind our shoulder is 7 8.
So al together so far we have 1 2 3 4
five 6 7 8 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8. And if you want to spice up that
section where you have the left hand
spinning and the right hand hanging out,
you can do so by doing some focus shifts
between your right hand and then back to
the audience as if to say, "Well, when
do you think I'm going to get it moving
again?" All right. So, we're going to
take up the entirety of the next eight
count with our windmills. The first two
in truvian man each take up two beats.
So, we go high on the one and low on the
two. High on the three, low on the four.
And then when we do the smaller
windmills up near our shoulders, it's
one count for each facing left, right,
left, right. So here we go. We go
around. One, two, three, four, and five,
6, 7, 8. Cool. Our next eight count is
going to consist of those weaves. And we
basically want to arrive for a new
position with our hands on every single
count. So from that last windmill, I
want to be thinking 1 2 3 4. I stall the
right hand on five, the left hand on
six, seven, eight, rest. So, putting it
all together from the top, we have five,
six, 7, 8. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8. 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8. 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 Cool.
So now let's do this to music. The music
accompanying this is an instrumental
version of Where Is My Mind by The
Pixies. There is one small caveat here
and that is that this instrumental
version is a piano cover and the
musician playing it is doing it more by
feel than necessarily, you know, having
uh a regular uh metronome or something
that they're playing with. So, the
beginning of the section where we're
doing the windmill here uh comes a just
slightly later than you think it might.
You kind of have to develop a feel for
the feeling of the song, but once you
get it, it feels super satisfying. So,
let's check out the full thing with
music.
[Music]
Cool. So, I hope you enjoyed that
walkthrough and more to the point, I
hope you enjoy the combo. Uh, if you
learn the combo, please post video of
yourself doing it online and tag me. I
am Drexfactor on most platforms and I
will go ahead and leave a link to the
audio track that I was using for this
down in the description. Did you get
anything out of this video? Please make
sure to like, share, comment, and
subscribe to help other people find it
and to help my channel grow.
This video and all the videos on this
channel would not be possible without my
amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now. Thank you all so much
for supporting my work. And if you out
there watching would like to sign up to
support this work, uh there are three
awesome ways that you could do it. If
you want to get your name in the credits
or access to any of a host of other
awesome rewards, uh you can go ahead and
sign up for my Patreon over at
patreon.comdrexfactorpo. If you'd like
to avoid signing up for another
subscription service, I get it. Uh you
can also send me one-off donations via
Venmo or PayPal. I am drexfactor on both
platforms. I will leave links to all of
these different things down in the
description. Thank you. And if you'd
like to learn more about dancing with
those windmills, uh, I did do a video
completely on that topic a couple years
ago that I'll go ahead and link to both
down in the description as well as up on
screen. Thanks so much for watching.
Make sure to get out and flow yourself
today and I'll see you with a new video
real soon. Take care now. Peace.